♪ ♪ ♪
- La machinerie fonctionne
à plein régime. La Commission
nationale du développement
et des réformes, en Chine,
vient de demander à 150 mines
de charbon d'augmenter
leur production d'environ 6 %
pour faire face à une récente
pénurie du minerai.
Elles produiront 220 millions
de tonnes de plus annuellement.
LI WEI, président
ShanDong Energy Group
- Nous allons tout faire
pour assurer un meilleur
approvisionnement à l'approche
de l'hiver pour minimiser
les interruptions de courant.
- Conséquence de cette récente
pénurie de charbon, des coupures
de courant perturbent
la production industrielle
depuis des semaines en Chine.
Près de 60 % de toute
l'électricité produite
dans le pays provient
des centrales au charbon.
Secteur industriel qui tourne
au ralenti, travailleurs
qui ne peuvent pas effectuer
leur production habituelle,
ces pannes affectent la chaîne
d'approvisionnement mondiale.
La Chine est souvent surnommée
l'atelier du monde.
"Les livraisons prévues ont dû
être modifiées, explique-t-il,
nous demandons même
à nos fournisseurs d'utiliser
leurs propres génératrices
afin de respecter les délais
autant que possible."
Le pays le plus polluant de
la planète promet de commencer
à réduire ses émissions de gaz
à effet de serre en 2030 et
d'atteindre la carboneutralité
en 2060. La Chine relance malgré
tout sa production de charbon,
une des principales causes
des changements climatiques,
afin de satisfaire la demande
mondiale pour ses biens.
SEBASTIAN WEISSENBERGER,
prof. sc. environnement UQÀM.
- Donc 31 % de toutes
les émissions de la Chine sont
dûes à des biens qui sont
exportés, ce qui est quand même
énorme. Évidemment, en effet,
on a juste à regarder autour
de nous, dans nos appartements
et dans nos maisons, tout ce qui
est fabriqué en Chine,
c'est ahurissant, hein?
- La Chine demeure techniquement
un pays en développement,
dont le moteur économique est
la production industrielle.
Le pays vient d'éradiquer,
il y a à peine quelques mois,
la grande pauvreté.
Ces données sont souvent
invoquées par les dirigeants
et décideurs chinois.
ZHAN SU, titulaire Chaire
Stephen-A.-Jarislowski ULaval
- Ils utilisent ce genre
d'argument pour dire :
regardez bien, oui, on doit
s'engager, mais il faut pas
oublier qu'on est en pays
en développement donc, en fait,
notre pollution, dans
certains cas, c'est
une pollution de survie.
- Et c'est là le grand paradoxe
chinois. Pays le plus polluant
soit, mais aussi le champion
des énergies vertes qui
compte le plus grand parc
d'énergie éolienne, solaire
et hydroélectrique.
Dans 4 ans, 20 % de
l'électricité chinoise
proviendra d'énergies
renouvelables. Et le reste
du monde profite aussi de
la production chinoise pour
les technologies vertes,
selon ce professeur.
♪ ♪ ♪
Mais comment aller plus loin
et réaliser la difficile
transition énergétique dans
le pays le plus peuplé?
La construction d'une nouvelle
centrale nucléaire est une
des solutions avancée poussée
entre autres par Bill Gates.
Mais selon le professeur
Alex Wang, il faudrait,
comme on l'a fait en Amérique
et en Europe, pénaliser
l'utilisation du charbon
et subventionner davantage
les technologies vertes.
L'atteinte des objectifs
planétaires semble donc reposer
sur cette volonté politique
du pays responsable à lui seul
de près du tiers des émissions
mondiales de gaz à effet
de serre. D'où l'importance,
selon Sebastian Weissenberger,
de présenter des objectifs
ambitieux en Amérique du Nord.
- Parce que si on ne va pas
rencontrer la Chine et puis
qu'on ne peut pas démontrer que
nous-mêmes, domestiquement,
on fait quelque chose qui a de
l'allure en termes de réduction
d'émissions, ça va être
difficile de convaincre la Chine
de faire quelque chose.
Alors qu'on sait qu'un Canadien
émet encore trois fois plus de
CO2 qu'un Chinois.
- Dans l'immédiat,
l'augmentation de production
de charbon illustre l'immense
défi qui attend la Chine si
elle désire vraiment atteindre
ses objectifs environnementaux.
(percussions)